most people think this fruit smells
terrible it's been described using words
like rotting onions or raw sewage
avocado it's a very good smell to me my
name is Chang tak seng de comité de
Rennes I am a farmer until now nearly 30
years selling urine beside a comedian
saying if you're not that familiar with
durian it has a spiky rind and the
inside is a yellow soft colored creamy
fruit it's native to Southeast Asia and
because of its odor is actually banned
from many public places urine is
forbidden in a par with hot air some
places they put a sign age that no odour
and allow the smell you can hide
my record is about 100 feet I can smell
you red
besides having a distinctive smell
durian also has a distinctive taste it's
like a peanut caramel they have five
flavor Street flavor
alcohol flavor bitter flavor flower
flavor and Nam taste doctor or five
flavor numb taste literally means your
mouth will go numb
Wow I can feel the numbness freshly
dropped Duran
the flavor is so good even the bees come
to the near end this might well be my
new favorite fruit people in general are
divided on this fruit
those who love it love it the durian is
so tasty
it's much better than it smells if you
really like Duran there can be like some
people may look like crazy like
breakfast lunch dinner
treemail are ordering they can eat five
seven fruits per day yeah and there are
others who just can't get past the smell
mmm I smell like Oh what they chase for
durian saying it is the perfect fruit
either you like it or you hate it
some people they didn't give chance to
taste but people to try once in your
lifetime
[Music]
you